in a small community in the Pacific
Northwest a dynamic company is growing
this company has served the equipment
dealer market for 30 years they did it
by following their principles by being
the best and by being honest to their
customers
driven
people focus
you know the biggest thing with a return
on assets is we have a lot of inventory
turnovers which as anybody knows
inventory turnover really helps win
with your return on assets because
you're able to keep that moving and
that's part of the reason that it was it
as as high as it was we had a very good
year both monetary and unit typically in
the moving the units really had because
we we have a large inventory for the
most part keeping somewhere around 150
units
used units on on these on the grounds at
any point in time and so we'd like to
look at it as if we can keep that moving
we're going to be more profitable in the
end which that's what the return on
assets definitely show and by moving on
that all the time yeah it's good it
makes us feel it's nothing else better
about ourselves from making a few sales
here and there too
in a small community in the Pacific
Northwest a dynamic company is growing
this company has served the equipment
dealer market for 30 years they did it
by following their principles by being
the best and by being honest to their
customers
be driven people focus